washington makes ohio state pass rusher
chase young the second overall pick in
the draft not a surprise at all there
was some talk about maybe someone trying
to trade up the falcons as of wednesday
night rumored to be trying to make the
leap from number 16 to number two it
doesn't happen washington goes with the
safe bet the sure thing a guy that some
think maybe even better than nick bosa
who was the second overall pick last
year the san francisco 49ers and think
of how bose's presence helped turn
around
the 49ers last year could chase young
have the same impact
for washington they got dwayne haskins
his former ohio state teammate last year
with the 15th overall pick now chase
young joins the mix montez sweat last
year was a second first round pick made
by washington those two can turn into
maybe the kind of bookend combination at
edge rusher that could make the
washington pass rush one of the better
attacks in the game we'll see how it
plays out for washington we'll have more
reaction to the picks made in the first
round of the 2020 draft as the evening
continues to unfold
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports